i don't want to be around the bush have
you heard of the save ima norway masjid
project your brothers and sisters at
islam that are establishing a one of his
kind masjid tawa and community center in
the capital of norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts islam through this center every
revert who learns about their deen and
calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video
do not think
that allah is unaware of what the evil
doers do
he only delays them for a day where
their eyes will stare in horror
let's listen
to this dirt bag
george bush war criminal terrorist
the scum of the earth who killed
millions of innocent iraqi muslim kids
even if they were not muslims even if
they were christians or jews or whoever
they was they were
look what he had to say and look how
allah exposed him with his own tongue
you think this is a chance coincidence
that he's reading from a script
he's reading from a script can you
imagine that he's reading from a script
and he still says a statement
which humiliates him
just a little humiliation the
humiliation in the hair after is
inshallah it's going to be worse
listen to it carefully the decision of
one man
to launch a holy unjustified
and brutal invasion of iraq i mean of
ukraine
all right anyway i mean just think for a
second guys
i mean
this is why we don't believe in
coincidences coincidences
allah made him utter with his own tongue
and that is exactly on the day of
judgment was going to happen wrong
sisters with his own tongue what did he
say the decision of one man
yeah to destroy one man
to wage war
unjustly
this very tongue the way it testified in
this dunya is going to testify to allah
on that day
we know the hadith of the prophet peace
be upon him of a man who will come on
the day of judgment and allah will take
his limbs to account and he will deny it
he would he'll deny allah will ask him
certain things he will deny and then his
limbs will speak and say no i did it i
did the haram with his hand i ordered
the killing with this tongue and his
limbs will speak and he will say woe
unto you
his limbs
for i was trying to protect you from the
fire he
was trying to save his own limbs but his
own limbs will testify against him and
if allah can make him testify and mock
him make him look like an absolute joker
do you not think allah will make that
very tongue and limbs testify on the day
of judgment inshallah we ask allah
and i say this
very hardly but it's from our religion
that allah guides him
or may allah destroy him into her pieces
for the millions of innocent children
and kids that he killed
may allah rip him into pieces in the
hell fire while
and i hope i see that day to witness
that and brothers and sisters just so
you guys are aware
do not think sometimes we want this
allah's justice to happen in this earth
while he will not be enough on that day
when you see you're going to say thank
god that allah delayed it till this day
because the punishment he truly deserves
forever is going to be justice
it's going to be justice because if
allah punished him in this life it's
going to be once killing him once what
bringing him back it no in the hereafter
there is no more death you will feel
that pain for the rest of your life if
you don't repent
until next time
i don't want to be around the bush have
you heard of the savimar norway masjid
project your brothers and sisters at
islam that are establishing a one of his
kind masjid dawa and community center in
the capital of norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts islam through this center every
revert who learns about their deen and
calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video